gone warfare is known for spoofing games  that we love in one of my all-time  favorites is grass effect and so what if  we made grass affect more than a spoof  when I learned that I was going to be  working on these e7 mech I was extremely  excited I really love the Mass Effect  universe PVC has this huge chunky  wonderfully cartoony style it meant that  I had to really exaggerate a lot of the  things in the Mass Effect shaped  language already blowing them out to a  more stylized proportion when I first  lot of designs we were really are you  serious this is super cool to have  plants vs zombies one of our favorite  IPS to be referenced as mass effect we  just thought yeah this will be really  fun to bring to the fans  you